how you doing I know haha we're friends
fans major friends fans I'm her one time
we play friends trivia did you remember
me beating you
yeah memory cheating you really did we
need a rematch yeah I still have a
grudge apparently we got a real Ross and
Monica thing we're gonna watch her miss
mojo today top ten friends plotholes yet
never notice I'm so excited and let's
see what we might be able to add on then
maybe they don't point out maybe perhaps
like it's not really a plot all about
how Carol is a different actress and
first season well yeah they just
replaced her yeah that's okay was one
thing that I still to this day maybe
they'll say something about on here that
I don't totally understand remember when
Chandler was gone for Christmas he was
in Tulsa zone with selma Blair with yeah
yeah and then he decides to come home
but it doesn't totally make sense
because like timewise there was kind of
like no way that he could leave work go
to the airport get on the flight and
make it home by like Christmas night cuz
he was on the phone in Monaco like at
nighttime the timeline didn't totally
add up to me my detective skills not a
real Frenchman it's much better watch
this video diamond
[Music]
as much as we love this show they seem
to have a hard time getting their story
straight
welcome to Ms mojo yesterday we're
counting down our picks for the top ten
friends plus infinity no fun seat
before we begin we publish new content
every day so be sure to subscribe to our
Channel and ring the bell to get
notified about what if we don't like
your concept they've got a debunk the
timeline number 10 Phoebe's knowledge of
French baby is easily the most
mysterious member of the friends gang
with information being revealed about
her one of the things that isn't
consistent though is whether Phoebe can
actually speak a second language in a
season 8 episode baby meets one of
Monica's new cooks Monica calls him a
sous chef and Phoebe is clearly at a
loss as to what that means
actually she's my boss who is French 400
so teaching Joey how to speak French it
appears to be totally fluent Jacques
Phoebe Chandler's ability to cry was
very sad when the guys stopped drawing
the deer titled the one where Chandler
can't cry the friends realize that no
matter what they do they cannot make
Chandler cry the entire plot of this
story revolves around the fact that mr.
Bing never sheds a tear it's a funny
concept but real fans of the show
remember several
your instances were changing the most
notable is in the episode where Ross is
trying to decide who his best man is he
gives Joey and Chandler an emotional
speech about how much their friendship
means to him and both guys start tearing
up hey Chandler never cry yeah we're all
the friends in a season 1 episode the
gang is memorably locked out of the
apartment while cooking Thanksgiving
dinner in this plotline the door seems
to lock automatically but if that were
the case how does everyone come and go
so easily all the time underdog has
gotten away in season 10 in another
Thanksgiving episode
Monica and Chandler lock everyone out of
their apartment to make a point but
Rachel digs up an old key that can
unlock the door thing is the locks on
the apartment were changed in season 8
ah
that's actually a good point number 7
the Curious Case of Ben
I've heard a theory that the bend that
they got is the wrong in later years
though Ben's appearances diminish and
eventually he seems to just completely
disappear
he's notably missing from Ross's wedding
to Emily which admittedly was on another
continent yeah I am parents surely could
have taken him to his final episode is
midway through season eight which leads
over two seasons with no Ben sightings
yeah they forget about Emma to never
once see him but his little sister Emma
ah never see that I like that I like
that one miss mojo we know that Joey
comes from a large family with an
abundance of sisters there seems to be a
disconnect about how many sisters he
actually has in a memorable episode from
the third season Chandler gets drunk and
hooks up with one of joeys sisters I
can't remember which one was it Gina
which one is Gina you see you kicked out
which is which either in that episode
there are seven daughters in the
Tribbiani family in season one however
Joey talks about his mother giving birth
to seven children seems even he can't
remember how many siblings he has to be
fair though we could chalk this one up
to Joey's was a handsome woman in her
day all right
you think it's easy giving birth to
seven children number five the apartment
numbers change or the show
Monica lives in apartment number five of
their building while Joey and Chandler
live in apartment four as soon as season
two however the number on the door of
Monica's place changes to 20 while the
Ojai's apartment becomes 19 - according
to some sources is that the show
creators realized that based on the
floor they lived on it would be
unrealistic for the numbers to be so low
their decision to change them however
arguably just confuse things even more
yeah I was lost this whole series 20
Geller Greene
they'll let you in okay number four
Rachel's history of kissing women okay
if you say that you kiss no take notes
Thank You Phoebe in season seven Melissa
a friend of Rachel's who comes to visit
and Rachel claims got the to kiss once
back in college
Phoebe refuses to believe her assuming
rachel is way too much of a prude to
kiss a girl the thing is though Rachel
already has kissed a girl okay so if you
don't remember that maybe yeah when
after Monica yeah that's right yeah yeah
anything to get it back she persuades
them is when they offered a kiss for one
minute and let the boys watch
considering Phoebe was sitting in the
background of the scene
it seems implausible that she wouldn't
believe Rachel later on that's a great
call good call miss mojo number three
Rachel and Chandler's memories in the
first episode of the show
Rachel shows up at Central Perk in her
bridal gown that are landing LA own
wedding
Monica introduces her to the rest of the
game including Chandler fans yeah greet
one another than they've been kissed in
season know she had a fasiq Miss Julie
another Lincoln High survivor this is
everybody this is Chandler and Phoebe
and Joey my brother Ross later in the
show however it's revealed that Rachel
and Chandler have actually already met
on more than one occasion in the one
with all the Thanksgivings coming to the
Gellers for Thanksgiving a couple of
years in a row he and Rachel have
several interactions including one that
we don't think he'd forget
number two's permanent marker when Ross
and Rachel fly to Las Vegas together
they engage in an escalating prank
battle that quickly gets out of hand
Rachel's made out with everyone she
fired that notices it she realizes that
try as she might there is nothing she
can do to get it off as a compromise
Ross lets her draw on his face as well
the two get drunk that night and end up
tying the knot the next morning however
the markings are magically gone though
mere hours before it had been impossible
to remove that's true before we unveil
our number-one pick here are some
honorable mentions Joey
[Laughter]
number one the gangs totally
inconsistent ages the most wide-ranging
flan the friends narrative is the fact
that people's ages and birthdays seem
totally random and unfixed Rachel yeah
what's your birthday why oh I'm just
making a list of people's birthdays Oh
mine's December out whatever throughout
the series several characters give
different dates for their birthdays and
for three entire seasons Ross claims to
be 29 years old what are you doing
making chocolate milk in the season 7
episode the one where they all turned 30
we see flashbacks to everyone else's
birthdays when Rachel allegedly the
youngest of a bunch celebrates hers
earlier though it's said that Joey is
actually the youngest there seems to be
no rhyme nor reason to the logic behind
this one well I am offended miss mojo
personal business I do feel like I want
to like defend them like that's how
close I feel they're my friends
bamboozled I'm a good manager nitpicky
well there's just so many seasons so
many characters that I'm sure it's got
to be hard I mean the one thing I do
feel like they could have maybe kept up
on a bit more is the birthday thing like
don't you think like the writers like
yeah like the birthday track their ages
cuz that was confusing I remember when I
first saw the episode where they all
turned 30 I was under the impression
they had been 30 for a while like then I
thought they were already in their early
30s I was like okay yes they all
recently turned 30 yeah I didn't realize
that this is not like a comic book
property this isn't based on a novel
this is a comedy show so a lot is
forgiven but there are some pretty good
points I do bring up
does disappear for a long time I've
always found it weird how there was so
much focus on the pregnancy of like
Rachel's forever pregnancy with you know
having Emma and most kind of just gone
for so much of the show and a big part
of the discussion of the final couple
episodes I'm Rachel is gonna move to
Paris I can't recall a line maybe there
is one but I can't recall much of a
discussion of what about our daughter
Emma you didn't even think of Emma right
there you see it's good boy it's like
they're thinking about their
relationship and love and I'm like yeah
it's the friends fan that's what I care
about but it's also important that you
guys have a child and what are you gonna
do with this child's life if this child
commute to Paris in New York the entire
time that's something that I thought
they should have brought up in the show
and it would have been cool if then met
Emma at some point yeah that will be two
spin-off it's gonna be a hard drama
about strange siblings getting to know
each other really though if come to find
out they took the wrong yeah that's the
twist abandoned child your friend
survival it's like there's so much time
in between that like I feel like we kind
of forget about yeah like the French
thing you know like there was a lot of
time in between that yeah I mean like
that to me is like an FAQ 1vb such aloof
does it really matter like yeah one day
she actually could have like just
remember that she knew French yeah it
wouldn't surprise me with her with who
her character specifically anything
would Joey especially about it blossom
sisters I mean there's that later season
where the sister wants advice from
Rachel because she's pregnant yeah so
that one's Deena and they don't like
show her in the group of sisters yes or
at least they don't call around maybe
later on they realized that they had
more kids than they remember and also
even with if you take in the Joey show
into consideration he has another sister
there so that would be nine sisters in
total if those two are not counted in
that original season 3 episode we have
with Rachel not remembering Chandler
that's a pretty big one a big one I
yeah I mean especially for friends Lord
these they've revised this [ __ ] as it go
you know and it's rare where the pilot
gets picked up because usually they do a
pilot and then they they do a new first
episode a lot of the time right and they
went with the pilot for this one you
know they didn't like go here's the
whole history we're gonna explore this
whole backstory yeah yeah forgive them
dammit gosh yes we will defend them my
thing was an honor that I said about the
about the Tulsa thing that's true
it's true maybe it's too much of a
nitpick French word is a big one yeah Oh
Rachel kissing a girl you see I could
chalk that up to Phoebe just being
forgetful again because Phoebe is a
forgetful person yeah we'll go with that
yeah see there's ways to justify a lot
of things also I feel like with Monica
it was just like a kiss and I feel like
with went on a ride or they had like a
makeout sesh yeah yeah that's the way
they made it sound cuz they were drunk
instead yeah and like the coconut bra
like knocking together and the locks on
the doors seen this whole show many
times I've ever been like hold up phone
they changed the locks and one season
didn't they but okay but they did change
the door so we could assume that true
locks door and then also with their the
numbers changing how it started off on
yeah three and four I didn't really even
notice that did you ever notice that the
number was different
no I'm surprised the writers that are
even like hey this isn't like kind of
everything that seems to be the one
thing we got actual commentary on of no
the writers had a big plot hole but this
one because there's so many episodes
later where they are on such a high
floor because they're like looking down
on the balcony and then they're looking
down a lot of stuff it makes sense that
they would be on a higher floor
I don't really know these are plot holes
one of the things that are kind of just
dropped Phoebe's parents that was such a
big through line for so many episodes
for her character journey yeah you just
don't hear about him anymore never hear
about them she gets married to Mike
nothing becomes of that I don't know I
wasn't been at his dad's wedding no I
said her dad it's the day yeah I guess
that would have been a big a big travel
experience for a little bin but I'll
give it to you
like I would have been a lot also
another one that's like doesn't totally
make sense but I feel like we just go
with it is when Janice takes Chandler to
the airport to see him off when he goes
to Yemen right yeah he buys a ticket he
like goes to the airport he's like I'm
going to him and I guess he like gets on
the plane yeah like did he go did he
come back and also like he just like
purchased a ticket it was like member
was super expensive and they did just
drop that and then when he sees Janice
Lee every season in Janice and never had
a line of I thought you were in Yemen
yeah exactly
holy omen thing just kind of goes out
the window too damn you are messing with
time line you know I'm telling my friend
this show is not as perfect as I thought
that would be no it's so perfect all
right guys well who's your favorite
friends character which friends
character do you most identify as which
friends character do you think deserves
a spinoff in a hardcore thriller and you
think you could beat Greg at friends
trivia like I did you know once
challenged me to French trivia when I
was on the set of Wizards of Waverly
Place season 1 Selena Gomez did and you
didn't you didn't accept the challenge I
did not
well I said well I said let's do it but
we never did it and then she got famous
and forgot who I was not cool the scar
to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow Ashley enter on
Instagram where it's all political yeah
let's end this with a picture of the day
shadow
Jeanne Jeter our buddy gene who we acted
to many of his videos before Shama
plenty of times he put out this video
just a few days ago it's called is it
gross weird food combinations taste
tests and boy does it live up to the
title I just got done finish watching it
just to give you an example of some of
the things these people do in this video
pickle beets with Smarties ice cream
Oreos dipped in orange juice Caleb
apples and mustard strawberries dipped
in barbecue sauce
I think there's 8 people in total with 8
different varieties of weird taste tests
some of the reactions they have are so
funny some of these I absolutely would
never try in a million years one with
corn especially guys if you're looking
for a video that is funny cringy gross
but just for entertaining throughout you
guys gotta go watch this video there's a
link in the pin comment in the
description box for this I really think
you'll get a kick out of it please show
support
I want more videos like this Jean do as
many as you can